and now to what's being described as the
clearest report yet on how climate
change is overheating our planet's
oceans and glaciers the UN
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change says the rate of ocean warming
has doubled since 1993 and will continue
to rise oceans absorb 90% of the world's
excess heat marine heat waves have also
doubled in frequency since the early
1980s and the rate is expected to
increase the IPCC says sea levels will
rise affecting hundreds of millions of
people in low-lying in coastal areas
before the end of the century and under
all scenarios the report predicts marine
life will continue to decline and the
report also details how glaciers snow
cover and Arctic sea ice will begin will
continue to melt
Greenpeace scientists are building a
case to protect more marine areas and
our correspondent Nick Clark is in the
South Atlantic Ocean off the coast of
South America with them yes we're on
board the Greenpeace ship Esperanza
where scientists are investigating a
newly discovered area of reef for about
600 kilometers from the mouth of the
Amazon in that direction and about a
hundred and thirty kilometers from the
shore of French Guiana and scientists
here on board a conducting all manner of
research from the seabed to the surface
hoping to bolster the case for
protection of the world's oceans to the
tune of 30% by the year 2030
the team here following closely the
publication of this report which lays
out in stark terms how the oceans are
warming the dangers of sea level rise
which could affect hundreds of millions
of people and the impact on biodiversity
in earlier we spoke to surge plane from
the French Centre for scientific
research and he gave us his assessment
the concern is first of all very
personal is that I I grew up with a
world with a certain scenario we were
certain vision of the world and then we
were certain wildlife and I'm always a
little bit sad to think that I will
leave to my daughter I've got a daughter
she's pretty young she's only 20 year
and plus and so I will leave that we're
all very different so into what I get
and so it's a personal Sensibility
first before scientific outside
sensitively on that in the context of
the IPCC you get to worry about life
being I've been able in several
centuries and and million m to adapt to
different habitats and then suddenly
we're changing that habitat with
transforming Adelita and so the the end
of these is the end up of those fauna we
don't know exactly but clearly they'll
be strongly affected yes the climate is
changing on the SR planets is changing
yes we are getting into over temperature
and this is this is this is gonna change
our our habits this is not gonna be only
changing the wildlife this is gonna
change also the agriculture this is
gonna change also where we living and
our lifestyle search plane then well
it's evident that the oceans of the
world are taking a direct hit when it
comes to the climate crisis it's also
clear that research and science the like
which we're seeing here on board the
Esperanza is crucial if we're to
mitigate the worst effects of climate
change abdullah mocks it is the
Secretary of the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change since he joins us now
on skype from Morocco Greek to get you
on the program thank you very much now
we've outlined a few of some very
alarming findings about the warming
oceans but if you had to address what
your most important issue is right now
that needs to be looked at what would it
be
thank you very much for giving me the
opportunity to speak about the outcome
of our special report about ocean and
Chrysler in a changing climate yes the
targets for any research and also in the
light what was have been found in our
report is we should give more attention
to all this research about the
possibility for those populations living
in this area with risk in order to
improve their ability to adapt to the
impacts of climate change and also those
are related to
the changes in ocean in food security as
well as she live arise this is I think
the main the main area over focus and
also attention should be also provided
to deal with how some minorities are
living like indigenous people and also
population living in the Arctic and all
those are reason for high mansion okay
the warming oceans will affect everyone
not just people in low-lying areas
eventually can you see these this being
reversed in any way can we can we claw
back some of some of this environmental
damage or do you think we now have to
think of a way of adapting to this sad
but new climate and environment that
that we have damaged so much yes I think
when we're introducing outcome of this
report is about a reversible aspect of
this climate change also damage I think
it is well stated that climate as is
clearly a reversible mainly in this
situation where we are living and we
also those strategy about the limitation
of emissions of greenhouse gases for
sure I think on what we can do now is to
think how we can introduce an efficient
adaptation for all the process because
now we are living in the scenario of
increasing in temperature we are already
around one point to increase in animal
if temperature and we are targeting the
possibility to be below 1.5 degrees
anomaly and also any action that can
lead to this limitation can provide the
possum
to have still the possibility good
adaptation possibility going higher will
compromise this this adaptation and also
will even close any possibility to to to
let the ocean area and also the old
region with the ice with their eye still
with their eyes and because with 1.5
degree C we can help Smith still some
area with eyes and say so much of this
is irreversible and cannot be changed in
the near future thank you very much it
was great to speak to you mr. Abdulla
Mach said secretary of the inter
government panel on climate change
thank you